i've been fortunate enough to sit there
and hear those conversations on a
private plane with
mj tiger gretzky jeter they are
so freaking competitive that's the one
thing they
all have in common what would they say
mental disorders they have they'd have
to
come up with something new if mike's
sitting right here
and we asked kobe what's the definition
of success what would you say their
answers would be
kobe said winning is everything talk to
mike whatever kobe would say
mike would have to one-up why don't most
people subscribe to wanting to find out
what their capacity looks like
and go at the highest level because it's
just too hard if it was that easy
everybody be doing it you've trained
the best of the best in the game of
basketball you said kobe worked harder
but
jordan worked smart what are those signs
that he said there's a very
distinct difference between this guy and
that guy with kobe
i saw it very early against utah when he
shot all those air balls for most
individuals that would have just
totally killed their confidence no he
came back and owned what he did
i'm coming back for more were both guys
that trusted easily
no they did not trust easily i had to
work harder than they did i tell the
story
about early down in the mj days there
was no fitbit
there was none of this information
available did you ever fire client
i've returned more money than i've
actually kept i had one individual right
in the middle of the game i told one of
my sisters to grab my checkbook roma
check i said here get out
we're in a society now where sleep
deprivation is like a sign of success
is the reward worth it winning is
everything
[Applause]
[Music]
so here's what kobe bryant had to say
about my guest today he said tim grover
is the master of mental toughness the
book is the blueprint for discovering
what you're capable of achieving getting
results you never imagined
reaching the highest level of success
and then going even higher the late kobe
bryant
here's what barclay had to say if you
compete at anything sports or business
or life
you need this book no one knows more
than tim grover about competitive
intensity killer instinct and crushing
the other guy
he is the best at what he does creating
champions and michael jordan
called him the [ __ ] not an [ __ ] he
called him
the [ __ ] which he took it as a
compliment so i can say to him because
he said
that's a compliment and having said that
he owns the record
he holds a record on by tim and i don't
know if you're aware of this record or
not
you held this record for a couple years
but just for a couple years
just for a couple years i'm gonna tell
you this you held the record for the
most f bombs ever dropped in an
interview
yes we counted it i think the numbers
you were counting is like 72 whatever
the number was
your record was broken by sammy de beau
gravano
he beats you because it was a longer
interview we had only an
hour he had two and a half hours so if
we put the optics together i think you
guys are very close to each other but
it's good to have you on buddy really
good to have you on thank you so much
patrick thank you it's an honor again be
back here with you
and i know you were telling me this is
your first uh live interview you're
doing for the book launch which we are
very very
excited about i know you're you know i'm
a big student of your
uh previous book yes relentless just the
fantastic but we had the entire company
rated this
completely different direction excited
to get into it i got a lot of questions
for you but before we
get into the questions in your mind give
me the difference between the book
relentless
and the biggest difference between this
book that you wrote that's coming out on
may 18th
relentless was a mindset it was a
mindset it was just like
what i was talking about with the other
individuals that i dealt with how they
thought how they went through different
how they went through different
processes
to get that end result
winning is in all of us
we all want to win but the path people
take to get to winning
everybody wants the end result and they
want to feel the sugar and the
the the confetti and all that other
stuff
but what you have to endure to win no
one wants to talk about
and that's what really winning is about
because you spend more time
enduring it and being in a pla
and not in a good place and i wanted to
bring it out and say hey
no matter what you do in life where
you're at
this is what winning takes and it's in
all of us it's in all of us you find
wins
every single day and when you find that
win
every single day you can get closer to
whatever you whatever winning means to
you
so winning is in all of us relentless
was more of a mindset this is about
going out and actually achieving that
mindset and getting what you want
at for what matters to the person or
is it more capacity meaning you know you
meet somebody where
you say this guy's got a big upset man a
guy can really kill it oh my gosh
and then he says tim i just want to be
an all-star i'm good with that man i
don't care to win a championship i don't
care to be on mount rushmore
i don't care to be one of the greatest
of all if i never make in the hall of
fame i'm going to live a happy life i'm
going to be totally okay with it
so is winning to you the individuals
level of success they want to have or is
winning to you somebody that goes out
there and says i want to find out what
my best version looks like i want to
find out how
what my capacity looks like how do you
judge it it's by the capacity okay
it's always a capacity you know if you
don't
people they look at winning
and finishing as the same those
individuals that you're talking about
they're just looking to finish they're
just looking to finish their career
they're like okay this is what
i got this nice house i'm finished over
here i made the nba
or made the end of that that's finishing
and a lot of people to that
they're like they feel like if they
finish they've won
these individuals it's a completely
different it's a completely different
level
so you have individuals that go out and
run marathons you know
if you compete at the highest level and
you're
a person that just runs marathon the
chances of you winning that marathon
are pretty much zero but you're going to
finish that marathon but
being able to finish that marathon puts
you in a mindset
to win at something else
so there's always what's next what's
next what's the next thing that's going
on you know we talk about what kobe one
of his biggest lines
is you know don't rest in the middle
rest at the end winners rest at the end
when you talk about fit people that just
want to finish
just what you said they rest in the
middle you know
for the longest time i was people asked
the question you know what's success to
you what's
you don't want those questions what's
your success oh the key to success
and i've heard a million different
things you know marry the right person
you know faith hard work save money make
money
read books you know do all the stuff
that we hear from a bunch of different
people
to me it was a alignment where
you know your values and principles
match the
lifestyle you're living so and not
worrying about what others think about
you but for you you spend a lot of time
around mike
mj and he spent a lot of time around uh
kobe
you've spent a lot of time with a lot of
other guys you know colton duane
pat riley you know whether it's barkley
you've spent a lot of time around these
guys
but if mike's sitting right here and we
asked kobe okay
what's the definition definition of
success to those two guys what would you
say their answers would be
well in the book kobe said he said
winning is everything
it's everything all right
and you sit here and you talk talk to
mike whatever kobe would say
mike would have to one-up them because
there's still
the competition never stops it's always
about
what's next what can i what can i win
more at
you know both those individuals you know
obviously kobe's not with us anymore
but both those individuals
the competition and the desire
and the feeling of winning even though
they were done with playing
manifested into something else you know
mj the most successful sneaker brand out
there
right owning a team tequila business
um in the sports gambling business he's
in
all those things he's in all those
things
all right so the competition never stops
with kobe
it was like i'm gonna win an oscar go
out and win an oscar
writing children's writing children's
book he was literally
his goal he would his plan
was to take over hollywood he was like i
owned
la on the basketball court
and now i want to own
la he wanted to take that was his
winning thing take the basketball out of
it
everyone knows i own la on the
basketball court
and we talked about this he goes
own la
own la and if you look at the paths he
was going through
that's what he that's what he was doing
that's what he was that was his and that
was his
next definition of winning i wouldn't
bet against the guy
i would not bet against him we had him
over at the event
and i uh uh gave him a couple gifts i
gave him a script i gave him a script i
think by uh
star wars and was signed it was the
original script and
you know he was fascinated by that like
when we were having a conversation in
the back all he was talking about was
storytelling storytelling storytelling
storytelling
it was like an obsession that he had so
here's here's a different question for
you so
the feeling of winning obviously is
a million times better than you think
it's gonna feel like surprising
it's just a ridiculous feeling i go
there movies
do very well because in the storyline
somebody ends up winning and the
audience comes and says oh my gosh what
a great
underdog story i love this movie pursuit
of happiness i love watching
you know invincible the guy ends up
playing for you know the jets a regular
bartender guy i love
watching this guy winning i love
watching all these different things
i think he played for the eagles uh
eagles you're right philadelphia that's
right i said jets
the story is about the city of
philadelphia you're right so you you see
all these different uh
movies do well because we see somebody
winning right we see somebody winning
why don't most people subscribe to
wanting to find out what their capacity
looks like
and go at the highest level they enjoy
the story but why don't i want to commit
to it
because they rather participate why they
they want it they want to just protest
they want to participate
in somebody else's win
because that's where their euphoria
comes from because they want to see
what they know what winning feels like
but what it takes to go down that
unforgiving
race to winning
they don't want to do because it's just
too
hard so they rather stay in the middle
they rather
stay because that's where majority of
the comfort is
it's in the middle everybody wants to be
seen
until it's time to be seen winning
in order to win you have to be seen
and once you become and once everyone
can see you you become a target
you become a target so everybody
everyone has their perception of winning
as this glory this glorious thing and it
is
and it is but the book talks about
everything that goes along that path
and what winning will bring you and it's
not
always what you anticipate to be
you can look at yourself yeah you can
look at myself you look at any success
you can look at any successful person
any person that's
going for more wins that's going for
their full potential
and they sit back and you have times and
you're just like
why am i doing this why am i do
why am i why am i doing this and then it
may hit you for a split second
but then you become i know exactly why
i'm doing this
all right those other people when they
say why am i doing this
that why wins with the people that
continue to win
that why doesn't exist like i know why
i'm doing this
so do you think those who say well you
know i don't know if it's something
worth me paying the price
is it the fear of the criticism do they
know that they're going to get that kind
of criticism or they don't know that
it's just i don't think it's worth me
paying the price to get this because
what if it doesn't work out and what if
i can't do it is it a belief thing
is it they don't have the level of
obsession is it they don't have the chip
is it they don't have the point to want
to prove to somebody
what what what would you point out it's
all the above okay got it it's all the
oversee what everybody's trying to
figure out
what what's the you get this question
all the time i get this all
what's the one thing well i wish it was
that simple
that's the one thing so everybody what's
the one thing to success
what's the one thing to your success
what's the one thing to making it what's
the one thing to winning
man if it was that easy everybody be
doing it you know people
they have everyone has
and this drives me crazy this drives me
this drives me absolutely crazy and i
was told by
another individual that the one thing i
have to do
in my um in my teachings is i have to
i have to do steps i have to do steps i
have to give people
five steps 10 steps so forth
and i'm not a step person i i'm just not
it's not something that's worked for me
it's not something that's worked for the
individuals i know it simplifies things
and helps people out
but when you look at the the road to
winning
people look at you and they're like
you're a success
all right but your road has so many more
steps
those steps are infinite sometimes you
get to see them
sometimes you don't sometimes
they're there other times they're wobbly
and you don't know if that next step is
going to be there but you have enough
belief in yourself
to say i know it's there i'm going to
take i'm going to take that
i'm going to take that step i may miss
the step i may fall i may
get i may get scraped that step may go
in a quick stand
but i know there's another step i know
it i believe inside me
that there's another step that i have to
take that somebody else isn't making me
take and you continue to take those
those steps are
infinite winning is infinite those steps
are infinite and you're deaf people
don't want to continue to take those
steps
i don't care what kind of shape an
individual's in the greatest athletes
all right as much training as they ever
do if you've ever had to run up a flight
of steps
it's hard it's extreme it's extremely
difficult
all right so when people say there's
there's the there's 10 easy steps or you
know there's five steps of greatness or
this
those steps to me are their steps to me
are infinite and even when you put that
plan out there people aren't willing to
even take those five steps
that's a good point tim reading so
intuition for you
you you've trained the best of the best
in the game of basketball
how what signs do you get i guess the
question for me would be
even prior to michael become michael or
kobe becoming michael or
you know kobe becoming kobe when you're
training somebody
what signs does somebody give you to say
this guy is potentially a guy that could
be
a guy at that level and at that level i
mean these guys have made it at the
highest level of a game it's not like
they're not the
cream of the crop yeah so you're talking
about whoever is in the nba today
they're they're they're a hollywood
celebrity on the back you know high
school campus
everyone on college campus knows them
then you're going to nba like oh [ __ ]
i'm a
bench warmer i'm coming up and it's all
start then it's this then it's that what
what signs do you see um where you say
this guy's different there's something
about this guy that's there's something
about her that's different what are
those signs they see that he said
there's a very
distinct difference between this guy and
that guy he's just as talented
she's just as talented but there's
something very weird and different about
his personality
what are some of those things he just
if you just pay attention to the details
you pay attention to the details
you could those distinguish those
distinctions are easy
are easy to see all right everybody
talks about working
working hard showing up early showing up
late doing all
everybody can do that everybody can do
that
it's the mannerisms of the way they
carry themselves it's the way they
compete
it's the way they listen it's the way
they absorb infra
information how coachable they are the
one thing
all my athletes
in business in sports
the best of the best are so coachable
they're they listen
they listen they absorb the information
they pay attention
they're there they're willing they want
that information and they know the
difference between
false information and information that
can actually
work for them you know kobe had a uh
with the first interview
they did um with kobe when they said oh
you hot you're uh you hired tim grover
you hired mj guy
you know uh what do you think about him
he goes
he ain't done [ __ ] for me yet i don't
know
he was like yeah he did great things for
mj and he's done great things for other
things
he ain't done nothing for me i don't
know setting the tone
right there how did you process that
when you heard that
oh i just i wouldn't expect anything
else i didn't do anything for him yeah
i didn't do anything and too many people
look at the history of what they've done
in the past they look at their past wins
their past
their past successes these individuals
they've
always want they you could when you look
at that competitive
person you can always see with kobe i
saw it very
early when the in the um
playoffs in against utah when he shot
all those air balls
at that you know he was about 17 and
always came in the league at 70. so he
was like 18 or 19 when he did that
right for most individuals that would
have just totally killed their
confidence
how is he how did he come back how did
he handle it did he run from the
adversity did he
run from the media what did he do no he
came back and owned what he did
and says i'm coming back i'm coming back
for more i'm coming back for more
for mj it was just never forgetting
that he got cut from the varsity team
when he tried out as a sophomore
and there's another story that you know
people don't know a few people know this
so he goes
everyone told him don't go to north
carolina
so he says no i'm going because you're
never going to play you're not going to
be you're going to be on the bet you're
going to be on the bench
so he goes to north carolina and i'm
pretty sure
um buzz peterson
was the number one ranked player
in high school that year and he also
went to north carolina
so dean smith comes in and they make
some roommates and he
and dean dean was like he goes michael i
want you to meet uh
i want you to meet uh bus peterson bus
peterson
is the number one ranked player
last year in high school as a number one
recruit and michael first thing goes to
dean he goes he never played me
how could he be number one now let me
ask you when dean did that did he
know jordan's wiring or he did not just
oh he so he did already so dean know how
to poke
yes okay that's it and he's just just
trying to just trying to see
because he wanted to say okay i know
what this kid has now how i just laid
something out for him
first day of practice let's see where he
let's see where he let's see where he
takes it all right and then michael's
responsible
how can he never played me how could he
be how could he be number one
and now people say things now are they
actually going to do it
the one thing all these individuals had
after each
championship while everybody was
celebrating
they would come and give me a hug and
say
what's next
because they're like you can't we can't
come back the same
if we come back the same
winning isn't going to winning is no
longer going to greet us
you know i have a thing in the in the
book where
the bus the bus takes you to the arena
all right it has it it says where it's
going
you get on that bus you win the
championship
and then when you get back on that same
bus after you've won the championship
the sign has changed it doesn't say the
destination to the hotel
it says this bus ride is back to hell
because if you're not willing to take
that ride this will be your last win
you know every single successful person
every single one that you
that you've had every single win
the next one's a little bit more
difficult it's a little bit harder to
get
you become more smarter you become more
educated you know
you know more but you can't come back
you cannot
come back the same individual especially
when you're trying to repeat
at something that you've already won
at so to win the first oscar to win that
second
it was anthony hopkins it was 85
85 i don't know when he won the one
before that
possible unbelievable unbelievable
but you those things are just they're so
and those are things you look for in
individuals it's just like you know what
can
what can it what can i see in um
game six after jazz
uh no this was uh this was uh with kobe
game six uh they lost
to boston all right and they're having
he's ha they're having dinner
and you know i i've never worked for the
organization so there's certain things
that i
i have to say i had to stay away from so
he's sitting there and he's having
dinners with with the coaches and the
team and then he's ha
different individuals and then you know
i get a text to say come on down
and he's sitting down called me and i
were having this conversation
and this is this is already you remember
he's already won three championships so
this was this was going this was going
for not number for this was going for
number four
and he's gone he sits there and he has
his conversation with me and he goes
man i hit him with everything with the
kitchen sink
and i looked at him i said when the hell
are you saving the sink for
and he just gave me that mama glare he
just
i said how many times do people go
through in life
what a thing to say back to the guy why
you hope that's crazy to say that
did he did his reaction to you get
pissed at you or was his reaction like
you're right what's his reaction
he didn't have to say a word okay he
didn't have to we were so
in tuned he didn't have to say a word
got it when a minute i saw that look
he knew i knew exactly he knew what was
he what do you think guy
was he what do you think i or no meaning
like if something's happened to the game
hey uh
tim what do you think about the the game
i played today no so
no he so he would want the information
but the thing is
we would only discuss
things that i saw that could have
meant could have been done better but
these guys are so in tune to what they
do
before you even point out they already
like i already know
i already know because their obligation
to themselves is so much greater than
anybody else's obligation to them
and they they understand the difference
between criticism and feedback they know
what the difference between
they know the difference between the two
and then basically the difference
between the two is how you hear it
mm-hmm that that is it the level of
sensitivity or
level of so how much of it is because
sometimes you give feedback to a guy
they're too sensitive oh my gosh you
know you're right i did this
is it that or is it then there's certain
people give the feedback to they're like
why would you say something like no it's
not it's not true i don't agree with you
or is it also the fact that the person
has to 100 percent be a proven guy like
you who knows what they're doing to take
the feedback from them
meaning kobe i'm sure he didn't take
feedback from a lot of different
oh you can't take feedback from everyone
you just you just can't very small
circle
very very small circle of people and
very small people who
who've actually delivered results that
have actually delivered results
were both guys that trusted easily or no
no neither one of them no none of them
trusted they
they did not they did not trust easily
they did not trust easily all right you
had to earn their trust
every single day you know people always
say hey
they said you got to respect me well i
had to give them something to respect
every single day
i had to work i had to work harder than
they did yeah i had to work harder than
they did you know i tell the story
about um early down in the mj days of
how
how i won and how i wanted to separate
myself when i first started with mj
there was no fitbit there was no none of
this information there was none of this
information
available so how could i do something
that i knew was right that would bring
me closer to winning that would bring me
closer to
him to say hey i'm paying attention to
the details
so i would go to the games all right and
this is
years going i don't know i don't even
know how many people in this audience
are going to remember this
but there used to be a recording machine
called a betamax or a vhs machine where
you actually have to put a tape in and
they would record
so i would record all the games all
right because when i'm at the game i
don't have time
i'm trying to watch what i'm seeing so
the games would finish
you know by the time we got out of the
locker room it would be 10 30 11 o'clock
sometimes we'd go out to get a bike to
eat so i get home about 12 12 30.
i have to rewatch the game because the
workout next morning is either at 5 00
a.m 6 a.m or 7 a.m
all right i have to rewatch the game
because i have to count his steps
i have to con i have to count i have i
have to count his steps not only just
counter steps i got to know how many
times he went right how many times he
went left when he went backward did he
land on how are you using that
how are you using that for what how is
that intel giving you
to plan the next workout so i like okay
so if here it is everybody like
when people go work out and they you
know they think about training they're
like okay
i'm going to do 10 reps on one side and
10 reps on the other side all right
well if he's gone if he's if during that
game
he's going one way more often than he's
going the other
i can't work out the legs the same i
can't work out the body
you you can't and i'm doing this and
people were looking at me crazy well
why does he have a 15 pound dumbbell in
one hand
and a 30 pound dumbbell in the other
hand or why does he have a basketball in
one hand
and he has uh he has a 40 pound and
people were just like what are you what
are you doing what are you what are you
doing over here
and i'm like i don't this body this body
this side of the body does not need the
resistance that this side of the body
does some days they may be equal other
days they may it may be different one
day we may all say listen we're only
going to work this half of the bot we're
only going to work this half of the body
out
we're not even doing this this half is
this half is designated for recovery
this half is designated for a workout
all right and those were the details
that i paid that i paid attention to and
that's
how i got when i spoke they paid
they paid attention they paid attention
to me winning doesn't know winning
didn't know my name when he doesn't know
who the hell you are
you know winning keeps his hands in his
pocket it's going to keep his hands in
his pockets you know why because it
doesn't want to point to anybody
who isn't worthy
tim have you watched uh tiger's
documentary i have not seen him yet
so i think you'll get a kick out of it
if you watch a documentary so
um i watch the documentary and i'm
sitting there saying wow
you know the role his father played
in tiger's life i don't know if tiger's
tiger without the father
you sit there and you think about
something from two years old so what if
your dad's like
if if tiger's my kid would tiger be
tiger because of golf probably not i'm
not a golf guy so
you sit there and you think about some
of these guys that get at the level that
they get
you know how the mom pushed you know
people think dad was a disciplinarian
tiger's mom was a discipline one mom
that was a little bit more
easy going you think about michael the
story with his that were the one part in
the last stance he says
you know his dad's like oh you know why
don't you just go out there and do what
you're doing you know i'm going to go
here with your brother
and his dad was kind of a challenge in
him he had some mind games with him and
he talked about it in the last chance
right and michael said
when you're going through it it's very
difficult it's torture because you don't
know what's really happening to you
when someone's challenging you i don't
know the story about kobe who was
obviously his father played and i
have that idea but i don't know you know
the role dad played
in a mathematical formula you'll hear
you know uh pythagorean theorem if you
take this and you take sure you take
this equals this right
if you want to make a bomb or if you
want to make an explosive you're in a
military your navy seal if you take this
you combine it with this you combine it
with this it equals
an explosive product that you're
producing right if you want to make a
milkshake you know you take this you
combine this everything has a recipe
there's a recipe
to the madness specifically to the
madness not all the other stuff
if you were to take the recipe of a
guy like a tiger or a kobe or a jordan
i'm specifically talking about those who
are
not one of the best i'm talking about
the goat league we're talking about
is there a weird family member
that psychologically mess with you a
little bit to challenge you
is there a massive setback in life with
a ton of pain
is it someone you love so much that you
want to make proud
is it a massive public humiliation you
know where somebody embarrassed you
is it is it the dna of the individual
because the same four kids could be from
the same family but only one of them
ends up becoming you have the same
pretty much structure how do you not
come out of it and all four what would
you say from your experience and i don't
even know if you have the answer to this
but what would you say from my
experiences
the one percent of the one percent that
people read about people write about
people watch
documentaries about what separates those
guys everything that you mentioned
everything that he meant obviously
listen
you're not going to be a great if you
don't have the genetics to be a great
athlete no matter how much training you
do you're just never going to be you're
never going to be able to reach
that level all right that's that has a
thing
that that pays important that pays
important role picking the picking the
rights
picking the right sport you have to have
there's always been an individual
that's held you accountable when you're
young it could be a parent it could be
somebody that's like really doesn't let
you
doesn't let you get away with things
that
that put that pushes you that forces you
to do things you look at the williams
sisters from tennis they're you know
no question yeah yeah there's there's al
all there's always that
there's always that individual yes
you've gone through some adversity
there's something there that you just
that you that you re
that you remember and you just like that
becomes you that's
that's your fuel that's like something
that
you don't need anybody else to light
that fire that's that's what
that's what you're that's what you're
made of and how you handle that
because a lot of individuals when they
go through that
when they go through that challenge they
go through that disappointment
other people make it too easy for them
you know because our job as parents our
job as individuals it is the comfort
it it is the comfort all right
in order to see winning in all its glory
it wants to see you suffer it wants to
know what you're made of
it it it nee it needs to it needs to
know that because
think about all your wins
you get to visit them briefly i know
individuals that have won
championships 12 years ago that are
still celebrating those championships
all right you look at your valuetainment
numbers or you look at your followers
you look at this you know i remember
when
you know you hit your um how many years
ago was it when you hit the
million i remember the hulk
two years ago two years ago when we hit
a million years ago when we hit him
all right where are you at now three
million
exactly how brief was that you're like
okay great i got to a minion i got my
plaque you did your little video you did
you you did you did your thing
and now you're like was there a big
celebration at 2 million
so is is that it no it was not we don't
remember celebrating 2 million we're not
even going to celebrate
so but but is it is it that
like there's a there's a story by patty
mccourt who was the former
chief human resource officer for netflix
she worked with reed hastings for 14
years she says
she says one day we had a meeting our
cfo brought everybody into the room
and he brings reed in and says hey guys
guess what what's that
we just crossed uh five million
subscribers at netflix and reid's like
no way
yes he says okay awesome
and we're gonna celebrate this is now
i'm gonna go out there and get to 10
million
everybody else was like no but we got a
celebration now that's great awesome i'm
going back to 10 minutes
the stories do is it
you know is it a level of i guess i
guess what i'm trying to get to is
okay question came the other day about
trevor lawrence being picked up as
number one and he says you know whether
i do this life is my life is not just
the nfl you know my life's big i don't
i'm sure you follow the story
you know my life's not bigger than the
nfl and then say well he's not brady
brady would never say that
right okay great and then guys came back
and said
i don't care if he said that or not he's
still going to kill everybody look at
eli manning he came out and he still won
two championships right
and then you know look at wayne gretzky
wayne gretzky wasn't a guy that came up
wayne gretzky was just a master of his
craft and he just
went up there and was a phenom and he
put up stats that's
beyond anybody else has done in any
sport no one's even close
if you look at baseball football
basketball no one comes close to
redskins separation
so is there a lot of similarities
between the the great ones all together
but
or could somebody just be like no i'm
just gonna come and do the job
and go out there and it's cool you know
i'm gonna work hard i'm gonna do my part
but i'm gonna make it look easy and i
don't have to be like mike i don't have
to be like tiger i don't have to be like
the williams
i don't have to be like these guys i'm
just going to come and win and if we
don't win a championship this year it's
cool we'll do it again next year but if
we don't win it's okay
is do you buy into what they're saying
about lawrence or do you say no to be a
brady you have to be a psychopath
competitor obsessive
to want to kill the other guy i don't
want to talk about people i don't know
uh
i i don't have a relationship with and
then i had that i haven't studied
but if you you look at all the
individuals that you've named
if you were to put them all in the same
room if you were all have them interview
here all in the same room
and you had a way to make their voices
sound exactly the same
so you didn't know who was talking all
right
they would tell you the exact same
thing i couldn't tell if i was talking
to mj i couldn't tell if i was talking
i could talk into kobe i couldn't tell
if i was talking to wade
when you listen to brady you can't i
can't i can't
there's things they say to the media
and there's things they say among
themselves and i've been fortunate
enough to be blessed
to be in those conversations the
conversation to be in those
con to sit there and hear those
conversations
on a private plane with mj
tiger gretzky jeter
to sit there and then have them sitting
together
and just sit back and just listen
camera's off they're just cameras
they're just oh my gosh and you know
they're not talking
they're they are they are so
freaking competitive it's
it's unbelievable and like i said if you
monotone everybody
the brain patterns and the way they do
things the way they pay attention to
details the way they relax
the way they execute the way they focus
it's across the board it's across the
board
that's the one thing they all have in
common they all
have in common if a psychologist or
psychiatrist was sitting in a room with
all those guys they would what would
they say mental disorders they have they
would call them what they the
sociopath they would you you have a you
know every
every every single one they had actually
would have they'd have to
come up with something new they would
they would actually have to come like
that
they would be just like you know they're
coming up with everything every
there's there's a disorder for every
they'd have to cut they'd have to come
up with something
because they would first thing they
would say
these people are different yes and you
know what different does
different scares people different
scares people that's why everybody tries
to fit in
all right winning requires you to be
different these individuals are
different
in the way they do
things i want to read a story from the
book
okay it's pretty crazy story you got
here in the book and i have a feeling
the audience can have the chills all
over their body when i read this
so there are no points every one of them
is number one similar to relentless
i'm not going to be able to get any
points but this is one of the number one
points
okay so you say on page 103
winning wants all of you there is no
balance
and balance you know is a very uh uh
trending topic
it's not healthy to not live a balanced
life it's not healthy to do this
but here's a story you tell when my
daughter was around five years old she
was watching me pack for a long
road trip and she asked daddy why do you
have to travel so much
this is how i take care of our family i
told her i travel for my work so i can
care for
care take care of you and mom and put
food on the table
she was quiet for a moment and then she
said the words that stung me harder than
anything that has ever been said to me
if i eat less can you stay home more
holy freaking moley
yeah oh dude
i read this i was like i was just kind
of like shaken by it
my daughter you know same age when
you're telling she's about to turn five
years old
how do you explain this to the average
guys like well that's why you should
stay that's why you shouldn't work that
hard that's why you shouldn't go after
10 what are you doing
is that really a good father are you
really doing the right thing are you
wanting to go through the pain
why don't you just kick back a little
bit why don't you just relax a little
bit
and the next part of that like i said
most people would be like okay
the story would be yes i unpacked i
decided to say
i kept packing i
kept packing
you need to be true to yourself and
here's the thing
[Music]
i knew what what she was asking i knew
what she was going through
but i i had to be selfish during that
time
and i had the only reason i had to be
selfish at during that time
is because i had a path
and a goal that i wanted her to be able
to achieve and her to be able to see
and knowing that i had to make the
sacrifice
now for the benefit
of what was going to deliver down the
line
and if i couldn't deliver what i wanted
to deliver down the line
it would actually be more detrimental to
myself and to the family and to my
growth
and her growth
if i didn't complete what i was set out
to complete
did she read this chapter she hasn't
they have i have not allowed them to
read the chapter yet
really yeah is this the same daughter
you're about to go visit or is this
the same daughter you're about to go
visit so
the topic of guilt okay i want to spend
a couple minutes talking about the topic
of guilt i made a video like two months
ago talking about guilds because
it it messes with people last night i
met the breakers guy comes up to me says
patrick i gotta talk to him and i gotta
talk to you i gotta talk that so what's
that he says i'm a real estate developer
i'm killing it i'm making millions i'm
doing so well for myself i married my
wife she's my sweetheart
i'm 27 years old i'm doing everything
and everything i can
but i got a six-month-old daughter that
just came and i'm going through this and
i'm going through that
how do you manage this because my wife
is a stay-at-home mom and she's trying
to take care of the kid but at the same
time i feel like i'm
over working in real estate and working
success all this stuff that he's telling
me right
in my mind i'm listening to this guy and
i'm asking myself first of all
there is no right answer i can give this
guy well you can't teach that if you're
asking it
whatever answer you give the guy's
already asking for permission to say
what he's just asking for permission is
what he's doing right
we're saying hey make me feel good that
i work less and stay home and kick back
and relax
i'm like i don't have an answer for you
buddy this is not a decision i make for
you no this is a decision you're going
to make right
how do you process the concept of guilt
with people who you get to a certain
level
and you're working hard you're like oh i
can compete with this level guys and
this is great and i'm going to go to the
next level
then you go to the next like okay six
months ago yeah
i can beat these guys as well and then
you go to the next level
and you're like i don't know about this
level i think at this level i'm okay
being in the
top 20 percent by there's no to be in
the top one percent of this level that
guy does that that guy does this guy
does that
i'm backing off right do you think that
is a decision the individual has to make
or do you think that is a decision that
somebody can be sold on by somebody else
most of the time that decision somebody
else is sold on by somebody else
that that you're deci to stop the
question i'm asking about the guild side
is the following i'm asking
a a guy's come in he wants to be a
killer
right but he's hit the wall where he's
experiencing similar guilt to the story
you talk about in page one oh
[ __ ] sure yeah so he's coming to you and
he's saying
look here's what i'm going through with
tim you know i remember that story you
said on 103 i'm kind of going through
this what do you think about this this
is that versus
the guy who's a michael or kobe or this
he already knows it by the way it
doesn't mean it's not painful it doesn't
mean you're not gonna have an emotional
it doesn't mean you're not gonna cry
about it
it doesn't mean you get in the car but
is it the individual's decision or is
somebody else going to sell you on don't
worry about it go think big go after it
it's an excellent decision it's yourself
it's the individual decision
it's an individual decision all right
listen
there's guilt that other people put on
you the worst guilt is you put on
yourself
all right everybody every single
decision there's so much guilt that
tribe people
people try to put not only are you
working so much
why do you need to go work out you're
going to eat that why are you dressed
that way everybody's all
those are all that's just people's way
of do of laying guilt on you all right
so people are gonna be constantly laying
guilt on you
it's the guilt you put on yourself you
make a decision to be this is
this is who i'm going to be this is who
i am this is
this is the person this is the person
and these are the consequences
that come with being this
person how do you have that conversation
guy asked me a question yesterday i'm
sitting there another guy comes sits
right next to my wife we're having a
dinner at this place called echo and she
asked well how do you deal with your
husband that's working like this all
this other stuff
how do you have that conversation but
believe it or not most people don't know
how to have this conversation right
right how do you have that conversation
because many times if you don't have
this conversation this leads to merit
you know this leads to issues with
friends with family with mom with that
falling out all this other stuff
from your experience i haven't been
around for a while you got wisdom in
this more than we do because
you're the expert in this area what is
the right approach to take with the
people you love the most
your wife your mom your dad your kids
have the conversation early have the
conversation often
but your results have to dictate
what you're doing that's it if you if
you tell
somebody i need 90 days you got 90 days
to deliver don't turn
five years later and say you didn't
deliver in 90 days
if you say hey i need five years this is
where i'm going
you better you better deliver in those
five i told michael
i said i need 30 days
i need 30 days before you before you
make any judgment
on the training anything that's going on
i need 30 days
30 days turn into 15 years
all right so when you tell those
individuals those
and those results have to not only
benefit you they have to benefit
them they have to benefit them
all right and everybody thinks about
benefiting them it just means you know
from a financial step no it's not a it's
not only a financial standpoint
if you're putting in all this time now
all right then when you do take that
trip with the family and you do that
you're in that trip with that family
you're like you're you're like you've
earned you've earned that time you've
earned that time to be
you've earned that time to be with them
when i was
when my daughter was younger
i would move to la to train
kobe that was one of his required goes i
need you to i need you to live here
so i would and my daughter was a
volleyball player
i said give me the volley give me the
volleyball schedule all right
and this is now from flying in from
orange county
so i would look at the volleyball
schedule i would look at
colby's schedule from a workout training
game schedule i would look at it
i would literally catch
a 7 a.m flight from orange county
land in chicago go to my daughter's
volleyball game
for 90 minutes drive back to the airport
get on the 7 30 flight back
and be ready for the training session
next day wow
how long did you do that how long was
that run seven years wow
buddy good for you man what a freaking
story
right there seven years now did i make
every game
no
did i miss events i did miss events was
it a perfect situation
no does it come with the territory it
does
unfortunately it does you know do do you
almost tell somebody
who like let you say i come to and i
said tell let me tell you
i'm not scared of these guys i want to
go compete with these guys and i believe
i got what it takes
i'm six six i got a 43 inch vertical
leap i got a good size mitt i got a good
quick first step i'm an 81 free throw
shooter in college
i'm a 48 field goal shooter i'm pretty
good at my game
i'm good i'm a guy that's coming up i
think i can play well with these guys
if i come to you do you tell me you sure
you're going to be okay with this
you sure you're going to be okay with
that are you sure you want to handle
this you sure you're going to be
accepting the fact that
you know parents not going to support
you how do you handle are you enter is
there an interview process or
all the all the whole things you know
everybody has
it's it's like okay this is what i'm
going to do
and this is what i'm willing to do do
those things match
you know everybody likes to tell you
yeah i want to be the best on this this
this i tell all people i said all the
time
i get that listen i'll i'll outwork
anybody i'll do anything i'll do this
and i'll say okay
i'll see you tomorrow for the workout
what time's the workout i need you here
at 3 30 in the morning
i can't do that what do you got going on
all right and usually when i say 3 30
they think about 3 30 in the afternoon
so everybody says they're going to do
they're going to do these things
and very few will actually follow
through on them fire client i hired more
clients and i've
i've returned more money than i've
actually kept any names that people
would know about
oh tons of names okay so you fire
clients you're like i'm not high-end
individuals high-end sports wealthy
all-stars all that i had one individual
right in the middle of the game he was
just like here i
i told one of my sisters i go into the
office grab my checkbook aroma check i
said here get out
what caused you to get to that point
once i put my reputation on an
individual i have certain expectations
the organization has certain
expectations so there's a trust factor
going in both ways if i can't
i can only do i'm only as good as my
clients allow me to make sense
i'm only as good as my clients allow me
to be my results are dictated by how
hard and how well somebody else
is willing to listen and willing to do
the work
and follow directions when i'm not
around that's
that's that's it all right i ca
i cannot physically put the ball in the
basket for you i cannot play defense
i can't set a pick i can't throw the
football i can't swing the baseball
i can't do that for you if i could
you and i would still you and i would be
playing mm-hmm we would have had it we
would have
we would have had a career all right
so the things that i'm requiring of you
those are non-negotiables in that point
you have to do
you have to do this you have you have to
you have to do this
because my obligation and your
obligation
is to yourself to your family
to the organization to your fans
to the people that sit down and watch
you on tv
and it's also to winning
when he wants to see how loyal you are
to it what what are you going to
do to get there
and to stay and to stay there and most
people aren't
they're just they they aren't why though
it's too hard same thing still it's too
hard it's just
it's just it it's just it's too
too hard is the reward worth it
winning is everything when i ask kobe
you know i have this thing in the book i
said the language of winning
and colby's answer was i said i said
winning is everything
just think about it
how good winning makes you feel when you
see your kids win
how how how good is this yes when your
spouse wins when your significant other
when your team wins
the feeling it gives yourself
exhilarating
it's everything yeah for that moment
nothing else matters
nothing nothing else matters
i agree i'm going to read some of the
principles you got and we'll get into a
couple of them here and then i want to
spend some time talking about the last
stance
got a couple questions for you on that
so uh
they're all 13 they're all number one so
i'm going to just read through some of
this here number one winning makes you
different
and different scares people winning
wages war in the battlefield of your
mind
winning is the ultimate gamble on
yourself winning isn't heartless but
you'll lose
but you'll use your heart less winning
belongs to them
and it's your job to take it winning
wants all of you there is no balance we
just read it
winning is selfish winning takes you
through hell
and if you quit that's where you'll stay
winning is a test with no correct
answers
winning knows all your secrets winning
never lies
winning is not a marathon it's a sprint
with no finish line
winning is everything freaking amazing
tell me about winning knows all your
secrets
winnie knows everything about you it
knows your addictions
it knows what takes you out of your
focus it knows what buttons to push and
knows what buttons to pull it knows what
you like it knows what she doesn't like
because it's you it is you
everything that you've hidden in the
closet winning knows all of it
it knows it knows everything about
yourself
the person that you don't want to deal
with the person that you
cheat the person that lights your fire
the person that
takes your focus away it knows it all
and that's one of the questions i ask
all my clients because i don't know them
i need to know everything that's going
on in your life
everything everything
everything i'm not here to judge winning
is not here to judge winning is the end
result
it is not here to judge
i need to know what distracts you i
don't need to know what
keeps you on what keeps you focused i
give you
i know you like stories so i'll give you
this i'll give you the story i'm going
to take the i'm going to take the name
out of it
so this was during this was during a
championship number um i forget i was
either number four or five with kobe
so one of the players all of a sudden
like a month before the playoffs
his numbers just started to dive just
started to dive and
nobody could figure it out nobody could
figure it out
so kobe goes hey i need to go talk to
him so i sit down and talk to him
he goes man i don't know what's
happening he goes
i'm working he goes i'm working out i'm
working out more
i'm staying in i'm not smoking i'm not
drinking i said well stop
you're not doing what he goes i don't
drink i don't
i said you've been in the league for how
many years now i said
every single game you've always
to say the time to change this is not
the time to do it this is not the
this is a well-known player everybody
knows everybody knows so he's changed a
routine
because he thought he it was going to be
better because everybody told him
that this is what you're supposed to do
this is what you're supposed to do okay
you're getting the playoffs these are
the things that you need to do but the
thing about winning new
winning knew all the secrets all right
and the things that actually allowed him
to play at his
best he stopped doing
because everybody said
this is these are detrimental to you and
for most
individuals they might be detrimental
but not to this guy but not to the but
not
but not but not to this guy it's just
like those long hours
long hours lack of sleep may be
detrimental to a lot of people maybe
but for some people it's not you know
we're in a society now where we look at
it where
sleep deprivation is like a sign of
success
like everybody oh man beat the beat the
son off they show the you know they show
the club
they show the time they're getting up
they show the clock you know it's 3 30
in the morning
all right so everybody thinks well if i
beat the sun up
i'll be successful if you're not
productive when the sun is not
don't beat the sun up so society pushes
you in these different ways what are
your thoughts on sleep
how did you handle sleep with your guys
how did you handle that
one of the most important things
i got kobe to do was to take naps
same thing with mj same thing dwayne all
my athletes
recovery is so you can do all the
recovery modalities in the world
you convince them to sleep sleep is
sleep is the is the best is the best
thing
so i would say just listen you can show
them all the scientific data you can
show them all that stuff
i said let's do this i said for for one
week
i'm not asking you for one day for one
week let's schedule a i don't care if
it's a 10 minute i don't care if it's 20
minutes i don't care if it's an hour
and so let's see how your performance
happen let's see what goes on with your
performance
when you take those snaps how do you
feel i just try it
all right i said for one week i said in
one week back then you're gonna play
maybe three games maybe four games
all right just go out and do it
and they saw and they saw it and they
saw the results you know
you got this beautiful bike over here
all right every you know how to make it
go
fast you know how to make it stop too
don't you
yes everybody wants to go go go
you got to teach you guys sometimes the
greatest individuals
you got to teach them to stop
now that stop is just for a moment
it's got to be a tough sell though man
it's the heart right the person saying
it for the person to
the individual to want to accept that
yeah it is and that's you know with
with kobe when i got him to do less when
i actually got him to do less
which was the challenge which was a huge
challenge
to get him to do less
that's when things really changed for
that thing's when really
his the longevity of being able to play
being able to play 20 years that's what
you said what you said kobe
uh worked harder but jordan worked
smarter right
yeah so jordan was willing to take your
counsel to say stop but you would tell
kobe to stop kobe would come back in the
afternoon shoot for a couple more hours
yeah
i i would like so we'd have these crazy
workouts late at night you know
kobe is you know he everyone knows about
those things
we'd work out all right we'd get done
he'd leave i would literally sit in the
gym for another half hour
because i know he's i know he's coming
back got it i know he's coming back how
much of that is because you're a
non-negotiable guy as well right you're
non-negotiable the guy tells you hey
when you get up on stage don't curse but
the guy before he gets up on stage and
he curses
you're like wait a minute why does he
encounter you you get a little
i have two non-negotiables one i'm gonna
deliver and keep my award but two
i'm gonna be myself so how do i do here
so is this an element of kobe saying
screw everybody this is my
non-negotiable
that i'm gonna come and do this no
matter what and he can't get past taking
counsel for someone like you
is that his inner battle that he has
that's an it's always another bat it's
always an inner battle and sometimes
that inner battle turned into a physical
battle
injury or you're talking no i'm talking
about between
us he's trying to get in the gym i'm
pushing him out of the gym
got it all right would he get pissed
we're like hey get out of my way i'm
going to do what i want to do yeah and i
i'd have to i'd have to stan i'd have to
stand my ground
i'd have to stand how do you do that to
that guy how does he listen to you
at that level oh well there's a lot of
adjectives and words used
that i use you know well
there's there's a lot of stuff there's a
lot of stuff going but if
you're strong enough in your you hired
me
to do this job let me do it trust me
let me do my job so so by the way is
that a sign that jordan's trusted more
than kobe did
no i just with i
with mj i started earlier in this career
it was it was in 89
all right kobe hasn't won yet that's
because he hasn't he hasn't yeah he has
he hasn't won
all right with kobe kobe had already won
he had already won he had already won
three i came in during
2007 i came in during the olympic during
the olympics
during the olympic times that that's
when i it's so
yeah it was a totally it was different
different stages
and i was only i
from an outside training standpoint i
was the only trainer mj had
kobe had been through numerous
numerous during that time during that
time a lot of them
so there was he had already had baseline
of thinking i i give a great a great
he would love to do track work who's
that
kobe would love to do he'd love to run
on the track
all right and he was always taught
to run in the same direction same
direction
same direction same direction all right
well i said kobe
if you keep running the bank on the same
way
right every time you take a turn
the impact on your knee is the same
because you if you look at a nascar okay
the the nascar all the turns are left
left left left so you can tell from the
tires
so he was just like this doesn't i
i don't understand what you're saying so
i just i literally put him in touch
with a pit crew of the nascar
individuals i said just tell him how the
tires wear out
so did both of them need to be explained
or did michael just take the council but
kobe needed an explanation
michael took the council colby always
needed call
you know when you interview when you
interviewed him no question about it
yeah
yeah he's an explanation interesting he
needed an explanation but both
crazy psycho competitors one needed an
explanation the other one is like just
tell me i'll go out there and do the
other guy said
hey i hired you to do this
he goes if i have to question you
then i've lost trust and i've lost faith
in you if i had so this was that you
didn't trust more than kobe did yeah but
he was but he would always
he would all he knew the difference
between if somebody was trying to bs
someone what was
what was real you know there's a whole
thing about winning never winning never
lies
so that's the whole point is just like
okay he just he had that
innate ability to be like yeah this
doesn't sound right
this this doesn't this doesn't sound
you're always like
is this a gimmick no like no no this is
this mic yeah michael says no no no
there's
there's there's no gimmicks there's no
gimmick there's no gimmicks here just
this is why we're doing it this and it
was a quick
it was and he wanted to see the results
hey let's do this this is
kobe need a little bit kobe kobe you
know more of a renaissance man did a lot
of reading you know
spoke what four or five language
proficient
proficiently i mean this was kobe could
have done a lot of different things and
he kobe could have been a private equity
guy
kobe could have been a uh uh you know
his mind is very when i think about
kobe's mind i think about an
analytical crazy genius
type of a brain that he had who have you
heard this
you've heard this story before who goes
out
and knows that you sign paul gasol
and the way you're going to communicate
with him on the court
it's going to be in spanish so nobody
else can understand what's going on
so you're literally calling plays
because everybody knows the numbers and
so forth you know everybody knows what
signs it's just like everybody knows
that
so no sign so he's they're literally
talking back and forth
and the other eight guys on the court
are like what are these two
what are these what are these two
individuals talking about you talk about
in the gq commercial gq video that you
did i think it was gq they did where
you said he was learning mandarin
because he was seeing the direction the
nba was going
yes what a what a visionary of a guy
seven years before
he owned i mean just unbelievable
i mean in china they love this i mean he
was absolutely they
and he understood because he started to
make those trips before
like he would visit china like not not
because nike sent him there just like
hey
let's me and the team or sometimes a
family let's just go down there so
people would see him so he started
he started to do his research started to
unders started to understand what was
going on
you know just like when he was a uh luka
dundas for dallas
he was trash talking and it's just like
luca was like
who's that speaking to me and his
language that's right
he turned on he was sitting yeah in his
language so he spoke you know obviously
he spoke italian he spoke
you know everybody knows he spoke
english he spoke spanish he spoke
mandarin and
you know whatever else he was whatever
else he was working whatever else he was
working on
fascinating thinking about this stuff
yeah but by the way uh
you know uh you said sometimes the whole
tire thing right when you're wearing it
out eventually you got your knees
because you know kobe had to omnia
yeah the situation you got your back you
got knees you got all this other stuff
what what are your thoughts i was
sitting down uh we had a uh
one of our clients that was here dr
guild dr gill who does himself he said
he knows you guys are good friends
yeah yes he actually sent me a picture
of you guys yesterday he was he was
going to be here today he said he had a
seven o'clock flight but
we were talking about you and he said
the fact that you went with kobe to
germany when he went through it i don't
know if you did or not okay
so what are your thoughts because right
now i was prp back 10 right and
platelet you know the whole thing that
was you know he went and got the
injections came back
younger rejuvenated he's going out there
doing all that stuff now you're hearing
a lot about
stem cells and athletes conditioning is
different players are playing 43 brady
winning the super bowl
you know maybe athletes are going to
push working playing until 45 who knows
maybe some guy next 20 years gonna play
till
50 with the way you're going right what
are your thoughts about the treatments
with prp stem cells do you have any
opinion on that
i just have my opinion on is what the
research is available
for some individuals it works
tremendously
it really does and then for other
individuals it just it just doesn't so
what i look at
is if you're dealing with an injury
go out there and study and try all the
modalities that are
that are out there that are available to
you do your homework
have your trainers have your medical
staff look at these look at the
different
look at the different researches talk to
the athletes that
or individuals that it's worked for talk
to the athletes that it didn't work for
find out where they got it what the
procedure was
all that if you're not willing to do
that have somebody else who is
all right but you have so much more
that's available
to you but also when you have too much
data available to you
it confuses you it really does it could
be trust what rod do you go i mean it's
yeah i mean you know you have
organizations with teams
that have defined jobs you know you ha
you have your athletic trainers you have
your masseuses you have your strength
and conditioning individuals you know
you have your data collectors you have
all these people
it's very hard to find individuals that
are all on the same page
because everybody's looking for the
credit
everybody's looking for the credit for
the success of that individual that
athlete
and so forth all right instead of
figuring out what's best for that
individual
the success lies in how the individual
the company
performs that's where the success that's
where the success lies and
it doesn't lie in the individual so when
you're out there getting make sure
everybody on your
organization on your team they can all
have
different styles you know you walk
around here
when we go back i remember this when for
our first interview
i was in a suit that didn't fit and you
were
and you were an olympian you were in a
leather jacket
sitting on some sitting on sitting on
some sitting on
two lounge chairs yes all right sitting
on it sitting on
two lounge chairs all right
that was our style
all right but our identity hasn't
changed
our identity your identity hasn't
changed from them my identity hasn't
changed
changed from them right your team can
have different styles
and you look at the individuals the way
they dress the way they do things the
way to handle business you know some
people like to eat while they're working
other
but the identity of a successful team
the identity of winning has to be the
same
it has to be the same you can call it
vision you can call whatever you
whatever you
whatever whatever you want to whatever
you want to call it all right
yeah it's just like listen
i've seen you transform from an
individual that
used to be in jeans
now look at your hairstyle you don't
constantly change it
changing your hair but your identity
hasn't changed
your identity from where i first met you
to now
is exactly the same
it's exactly the same because you know
who you are if winning's not gonna lie
you can't lie to winning too many people
don't know who they are and they lie
they lie without even saying a word
there's so much truth behind that you
know uh um i'm in um
i'm in palm beach i'm looking at a house
realtor who comes and starts talking to
me my realtor says i just want you to
know
i'm the best of the best in fort
lauderdale but this guy's the best of
the best in palm beach
i sell 20 million dollar homes this guy
sells 100 million dollar homes he was
selling trump's house for like 140
million
and he takes and shows us the house like
sly just bought the house he sold him
the house and we looked at the house yet
because it was his house
before he sold it to sly for like
whatever the number was 35 million
and while i'm with him he gets a call
from uh steve wynn so say hey what's up
hey i'm here with a friend patrick hey
what's going on back and forth
and then i said so how long have you
known when
trump all these guys how many of these
guys do you know he says 35 years i've
known these guys
okay tell me the personality so it
starts kind of telling me the
personality all this other stuff
he says you know some of the guys that
make it at
the small percentage of you know one
percent of one for whatever that number
is
they have very few friends they have a
lot of people they know but they have
very very few friends
how hard is it to be friends with a guy
like was there a
was michael moore a friendly guy who he
had a lot of friends
or you know kobe is known for not being
a guy that had a lot of friends he was
kind of a loner himself he was more to
himself than it was the other way around
but
what what could you say about who they
let in and how easily they befriended
people
they led very few people in and they
both of them didn't have a lot of
friends
they just didn't why do you think that
it is well
[Music]
one
they don't really look for friends
they look for allies there's a huge
difference
a friend comes and goes when things are
good and they're gone when they're bad
and friends don't have answers friends
give you the answers when something
isn't going well they say oh it's going
to be okay
tomorrow's another day these guys
they're not looking for
they've never settled for okay in their
life so if you tell them everything's
going to be okay they're like that's a
miserable day
that's a miserable day they're not
looking for friends they're looking for
allies they're looking for
allies well winning doesn't have any
friends
everybody that's one they're all allies
because
they can relate to each community got it
all right so those those are those are
the individuals
allies tell you what you
need to hear not what you
want to hear is it because they all
speak the same language and nobody else
speaks the language they speak that the
mindset language whatever that may be
yes and it's speaking in very few words
the truth the how old are your kids
974. all right so here's the thing
you can always tell when a kid's gonna
fib something because the story gets
real real
long it just gets a little longer and
long and that doesn't change
with individuals you can the truth is
simple
it takes very few words people
understand it
it's that when is the right time to tell
the truth it's always the right time
it's always the right time those
individuals they don't want to be bs
allies will not bs you when you're
performing well they'll let you know
when you're not performing well they'll
let you know if you're doing something
destructive
they'll let you know and sometimes your
allies aren't even
your closest they're not even your
closest associates
they just pop in to be like they hold
you accountable and they and they and
they leave
that's it but people don't want to be
surrounded about those guys because
you look in a relationship winning
requires
it requires all of you and if it
requires all of you it requires you to
be honest
so people cannot be honest people cannot
be honest with themselves
they can't be honest with other
individuals what's the first thing
people say they want in a relationship
honesty until you're honest with them
[Music]
so what happens when you when you are
honest with an
individual and you tell them the truth
it's supposed to lead to better
performance
better understanding what's it usually
do
it leads to more emotions and more
emotions lead to what
less productivity less
less of every less of everything because
now you have to deal with an emotional
situation
these people know
how to go from one emotion to another
quickly they know how to go from fun to
serious
serious back to fun quiet to loud
loud to quiet they have that they have
that ability to go what a crazy thing
you just said
you know they said that about tupac i
don't know who was talking about tupac
he says one day i'm
uh sitting out with tupac one minute is
a poet one minute he's a
philosopher one minute he's a crusader
one minute he's got
thinking about his enemies one minute
he's this his mind was is it the level
of creativity or is it the level of
focusedness or is it the level of they
they feel all the sensitivities they're
aware of everything that's going on they
are so aware of
everything that's going around them they
are so
does the smallest thing bother them is
it the slightest thing could bother them
or no
it could i i won't say it bothers them
they know how they know whether they
need to use it or not use it
they have the shortest memories they
don't forget
it's obvious from last dance yeah they
don't they don't forget supposed to kill
this guy
you know they don't forget but they have
the shortest memories
and what i mean by the shortest memories
is
i've always said that to the greatest
athletes out there thinking is a
distraction
because if you're thinking you're not in
the moment but it takes
years and years and years and years of
thinking
not to be able to think
not to be able to think so these
individuals that can
go from one emotion to another they can
go from laughing to serious they can
they have that ability to know
what they can use and what they can't
use and they can get rid of it real real
real real quick real real quick
yeah i i asked this because you think
about
michael and chuck right charles
phenomenal relationship great friendship
they got and then all of a sudden one
day they're on
you know the oprah winfrey one you know
this kid where you know
charles is wearing the blue you know a
jumpsuit michael comes out in a nice
thing and they're just taking
shots at each other taking shots at each
other and then the friendship has fallen
out
that's what i mean at one point what is
the fallout for
is it personal is it why decide with him
how could you say that guy's a better
player than me are you freaking kidding
me you know i crushed you when we played
what what what gets a guy at that level
to stop a relationship with a guy like
charles you've known for 20 30 years
they just decide one day i'm not doing
this anymore
and maybe whatever whatever reason
whatever reason it is
you know i i don't know what obviously i
know what's been in the media and what's
been going on
but they just when they decide they make
a decision they don't make a suggestion
they make a decision
think about yourself you made a decision
to move your family to move to this
location
to separate the two business those are
all decisions
how many individuals do you know are
still making suggestions
in order to win you got to make
decisions
you can't you can't make such a yeah you
got you got you got it you met
you got to make you got to make
decisions winning that's the first thing
winning require
are you deciding or are you suggesting
to be
in this unforgiving race what are you
doing what are you doing
make sense michael made a decision and
boom that's what happened that's it
that's what happens
i mean listen i think the world would
love to see those guys back at it again
talking to each other that's going to
come up i think it's
eventually going to happen i agree with
you he's going to do very good i agree
with you charlie you got to love charles
i mean charles is the best guy on tv i
don't think anybody can i don't know how
many awards this guy's won
and michael is there any athlete that
people are more enamored by than him i
don't think so those two guys come
together
it's just like so so let's talk about
the last stance okay the first time you
and i sat down i brought up
uh lebron james and you had at one point
said lebron james was a closer but you
said that like 12 years ago or 10 i
don't know the exact timeline
you said that even maybe when the book
came out you considered him a closer not
necessarily cleaner and you have the
whole cooler
right closer cleaner and the cleaner
guys like michael
and all these guys that are cleaners
okay great
he's a cleaner now he's okay so here's
my question for you here's my
question for you um he's got four now
he's a laker now he's one with miami
he's one with cleveland he's one with so
he won for the city he won for two miami
he's over here now okay
do you think the last dance is the worst
thing that ever happened to the argument
of him being the greatest and passing of
michael
i don't even think so before the la
listen i'm going to be subjective on
this obviously because of my
relationship we're not running for
officers don't be right
i'm just saying all right i think even
before the last stance it just wasn't
the only reason i say this is because
here's here's why i say this
so i'm 42 i think if you're above 35
there is no argument correct okay if
you're buying it there's no argument
right
but do you think the 22 year old guy the
28 year old the 26 or maybe they didn't
get a chance to watch
on saturday morning michael's coming up
against chicago he scores 52 points 55
points all this other stuff you would
see the guy's killer instinct
do you think the 22 year old like a
generation that missed watching this guy
play said
that guy is a scary guy to face up
against you think
last dance hurt those guys's argument
oh yes it just it's just
there's so many the younger i i've had
so many people that come up to me
and say the footage of mj on youtube
is enhanced there's no way there's no
way anybody can do it
they're like they're photoshopping yeah
they're just like jumping they're just
like there's no way he there's no way
there's no way he can do that all right
and i've had so many individuals now
they're just like
it's just like because they didn't get a
saint they're just like mj's just a myth
and ghost to us
we hear all these we hear all these
stories and we
you know we've heard all these things
and it's just
they just can't they just can't comfort
they just can't comprehend it
they just they just can't comprehend so
the debate for you
it wasn't even a debate before but the
debate for you even afterwards nothing
changed for you but for somebody else
maybe they said
this wasn't my lebron's probably
watching that thing saying
oh they're going to say this they're
going to say that they're going to say
this that's not good
because you know lebron's a legacy guy
he said i'm chasing the ghost so it's
not like he hasn't put it out there
right when he came out and said
he's chasing one gun when he dunked the
ball and he's looking at yeah he's
sending a message he is sending him
i wasn't looking at him i was just
dunking the ball but you know
what he's doing okay so who's
on your top five all time do you have a
top five all time where you go you know
let's say michael's the greatest and the
second do you have
obviously obviously my michael's going
to be michael's going to be on there
all right um
i'd have to put i'd have to put well you
know what here's the thing if you look
at
depending on the error of the game if
you're just it could it could be
it's so different i mean if you're
looking at the older game you watch
you definitely want shaq in there all
right you're just the way he was
probably
the most the most dominant player that
he just gave him the ball and he just he
just literally ran through everybody
it i would probably i would want uh
i would take mj i would take kobe
i'd put lebron
larry bird
and who would my big be
a shag kareem wilt
maybe akeem but he would probably yeah
you know i worked with akeem so it's
kind of difficult for me to keep him all
keep him off that list but the way the
game is played now is just like
i'd say shaq shaq yeah
that's a great list right there that's
you know you got
it's hard to leave burden top five yeah
you know why in this game here
people forget he's another one you go
watch this he could do
every larry bird on a game decided
i'm just gonna go shoot with the left
hand today
who does that he's like you're so bored
with the competition
that you come out and says ah
i don't know if it was the first half or
whatever happened he says i'm just going
to shoot the ball with the left hand
who does that who
who who does that he wasn't afraid of
anybody
nobody and could do it all yeah could do
it could do it all
you know one of the reasons i put
obviously defense isn't uh isn't a
primary thing
in this sport anymore but you know
obviously we know michael could play
unbelievable defense we know colby could
play under
unbelievable defense uh lebron when he
chooses he could play he
he can he can lock them down if they do
get around anybody you got this big mon
you got this big monster in the middle
destroy you scared the hell out of you
oh and all those individuals the one
thing they have
is the ability to make everybody else
around them better
that's the thing they all have the
ability to make everybody else
dr jay comes out and he talks about i'm
sure you saw when he comes down he says
hey you know what do you think about
your top five and he puts his top five
it says first team second team first
team oscar robertson jerry west elgin
baylor bill russell will chamberlain
which obviously that's his era
get it and then he says second team he
would put magic
michael larry malone kareem
the second team so obviously kobe's not
on the list if you had to choose between
i think the way he did it is positions
one two three four five is the way he
did it
so he chose kobe over uh he chose
michael over kobe he chose magic over
steph curry he chose bird over say
lebron james he chose
malone over duncan and he chose kareem
over shaq
right and then they asked him they said
wait a minute where's lebron on this
list
and he said what were his words he says
he is the guy who has
led the change in terms of super teams
when he put together a team in miami he
put together a team in cleveland as well
and he put together a team in la
so he can pick his own team i ain't
going to pick my own team the guy turns
around and says
i'm sure he said he says well lebron's
verdict would be
there's been super teams for a long time
everybody's had super teams you guys had
super teams there was typically three or
four all-stars on the same team he says
yes
last words yes but we didn't go
recruiting
players he did so one thoughts on what
he says
two what do you think about lebron not
being on his top five
well i mean obviously the top five is
what you said that that's his heir these
are the people that he knows with listen
when you go to war
you're going to go with what you you you
need to go to war
with the makeup of the people that you
know that you can trust
you know your allies these are his
allies make sense these are his out
by the way it's a great list
you literally got the records wilt has
is unbelievable you talk about
championships you know everyone
that that's that's the guy elgin baylor
was that
the first person to do all this stuff
the triple double hair jerry west logo
the logo yeah
does anything anything else needs to be
uh anything else needs to be said
so that says it this was the era these
are a lot of these individuals
he competed you know he competed he had
he competed against
dr jay competed again you know a famous
fight with him and uh
when who was holding up was moses malone
holding him somebody was holding a
bird by the neck and julius punch them
three times
away you know whatever it is and you
know michael is obviously everybody said
you know he's the
he's a heir apparent to to die to dr j
so he's had he's had all the respect
here you know obviously i'm not
he did it he did it by he did it by
position
all right what if i'm putting this if
i'm putting this team together
i would um
if i had to take one person out out of
here
what depends on if i had to take one
person out of my second team
i have a feeling i know who you're gonna
take out carl malone who'd you put him
instead of him duncan
i would put yeah i mean out of this team
keeping lebron out of here if we're
going to keep lebron out of here
all right i would put down i would put
dunk even if you think about this i
don't know
i would put charles before a call i
almost
i'll put charles before carl really yeah
i almost think he went 60s 70s 80s 90s
because i don't think he went
2000 2010 and today because maybe he's
going through era
then he's going through the greatest i
don't know if that's going to be his top
five list
himself but uh you know again the last
dance when i watched i was sending you a
text i'm like
tim this is insane with the stories that
you're hearing about the sky left and
right everything that you're hearing
it's true
that's what makes it when they recorded
it did they
know when they recorded that season did
they know eventually they're gonna do a
last dance
so that that was the plan so that was
always the plan
but the only person that didn't sign off
phil or michael was michael everybody
else signed off
years ago like i'm not signing off he
goes
when it's time or when i decide to do
this i will sign off
and originally it wasn't even supposed
to it was supposed to come out in the
fall
by the way i mean timing wise you have
the timing kind of worked in their favor
yeah so they were just like the last two
episodes weren't even done when it when
it started
the last two episodes were not done
they were wait so so when we sat down
and we watched the first week on sunday
night they had still not finished the
last two episodes the last two episodes
were still
not done because they hadn't planned on
showing it until but then because
of the pandemic and everything had and
you know everybody there's like
everybody
so they they literally went in and asked
hey
we need we want to move the production
up so they got in to
move the production up and it was you
know that's every everybody
the one thing i i have to say about
michael and this is why i put him above
everybody
whether it is kind of like tiger also
whether you were a basketball fan or a
golf fan
you were a fan of that you watch if you
didn't enjoy golf
you would literally you look up the
paper to see what tiger did or where he
was playing what was going on
i had so many people that i'm not a
basketball fan but i'm a michael jordan
fan
so you had those those individuals
transcended individuals that had no
interest in that sport you're going to
love
tigers in a documentary by the way
you're going to love tiger's documentary
because they talk about that they talk
about what he did to the game of golf
and how much it changed and how many
people are not watching like the moment
you hear about it he's not in the
masters
i have no interest yeah and i'm not
obviously i'm not a golf
i have no but when tiger was in it glued
to the screen
what's he gonna do here at the
restaurant can you please change your
channel from the football game
let's see what tiger's got you were
curious about what he was gonna be doing
i'll explain to you why for you
i'm curious it's his identity
you relate to his identity
to tiger's identity you relate to him
when i
it's i'm telling you when you watch
tiger's documentary it's very very
interesting documentary and i do relate
to the guy when i see him i look at him
i'm like oh my gosh i'm fascinated with
the way
this guy thinks like you look we were at
a uh
uh poker tournament he put together
it was myself it was phil hellmuth it
was uh
tiger westbrook and you're just watching
this guy
on where he is and what state he's in
very unique character i would have loved
for him to get his 19th
but today after what just happened
recently i think that's very unlikely
have taken place
last thing you do we do before we wrap
up here
and you know i can talk to you for hours
you know these conversations this is
what
this is my drug i love hearing this
mindset
of winning you you uh you use a very
technical scientific terminology in the
book
that i i would want you you know to
share with the audience obviously your
background in kinesiology
this this scientific terminology you use
the idgaf can you tell us a little bit
more about it you know what what do you
mean by that they have this mindset
that mindset is this comes with a
disclaimer i've done pretty good at
keeping the language fantastic today
you know what patrick you'll never
forget this
we did an event together
i don't remember where i don't remember
where it was but you and i did an event
together
and i remember you telling me you you
actually and i don't know if this talk
was actually directed to me or not
but you had said something about
the language thing and i took it to
heart
i took it to heart i listened i wasn't
offended i wasn't listened
because my agent sherry was telling me
the same thing
she was telling me she was telling me
the same thing she goes you have to know
when to place and when not to and i
remember everything that you told me
about the thing
listen yeah we joke about i had the
record for it yes but
if i was still doing that you wouldn't
have done it that way you would have
changed that
i would not say i'm talking about if i'm
still doing it now
all right that means i didn't i didn't
evolve as a
as a better speaker i didn't have more
to say my language what my language was
my my language was my words was it was
limiting
it was limiting it was i took that i
took that a heart most people that's why
i said this feedback and criticism
sometimes
it's not dr people may be sending you a
message
they may they may it may be directed to
you but it's not me it's memory
yes i remember it was an award ceremony
night and you went up and there's i
think
four people were asking you questions
and they were kind of interviewing you
you know the setting that you had
do you remember where was that was it
new orleans or no was it
and i just said you know what in order
for my next evolution
is that something that i need to work on
i do i need this is this is a grow this
is a growth process i mean i could have
easily said ah forget that
but going back to the idea that listen
it's a i don't give a [ __ ] muscle
and you work out you're you know people
if you go with the history of you
people don't know where one of your main
goal is to be a professional bodybuilder
you've had
numerous professional bodybuilders on
this show
and you you know you've talked to them
because their minds
you talk about a sport where details
and there is no off like you can
in basketball and football all these
individuals
when they're when they're training and
they're doing preparing for a game or
whatever
they can still have a slice of pizza
they can have a beer they can have a
glass of wine
those bodybuilders they can't
especially if you wanted back to like a
phil doing at seven like
ridiculous too yes they disappoint that
long uh and then go off what did he took
what a year and a half off and finish in
the top three coming back i mean it's
just like you said maniacal
but we all have that muscle
but just like any other muscle
in your body that muscle people don't
train enough
and it gets weak and it gets soft so
when you need to use it
you don't have the ability to say it all
right
so i don't give a [ __ ] muscle is that
muscle
inside of you that blocks everything out
regardless of what anybody else anybody
that doesn't mean you're not open to
feedback and criticism
but it doesn't it takes you away from
all the naysayers from all the haters
from all all the
lack of focus from everything else
that's coming that that's coming in
that's that's trying to derail you or is
that natural is that like
i think do you think this is something
that you learn like there are certain
parts of the game that you got to learn
do you think this is where
michael had to go and say dude listen i
honestly don't give a flying you know
what just who
is it an evolution for the individual
it's an evolution and the one i i would
say the individual that's probably that
the younger audience can relate to more
than anybody else is lebron on this
we talk about in the book winning you
know when he when he first started with
the media
he was extremely sensitive to what
everybody says now it's at the point
he's just like
here it is this is what i'm going to
talk about
here's my answer this is what this is
what this is what i'm going to do
he that's one of the muscles he
exercised throughout his career that is
so freaking powerful it's a good point
that is so good that is so powerful
and he's he's probably gonna gonna be
politically this guy's not going away
he's gonna be doing stuff the next few
decades i think he's got big aspirations
and yeah he's also another guy that's a
pretty smart guy
i don't know when it was when he started
reading a lot of books you would see him
be pre-game
you know going into the playoffs he's
got the book there he would you know get
away from
social media and would just stay focused
on his game his
every individual around him
that he keeps around
and this is very special they're his
close friends and they're his allies
very difficult to find both
very difficult to find it's funny you
say this because we were talking about
mark wahlberg
and mark would talk about you know
everybody that's around him right now is
people that he's known since he was a
kid you know when he's coming up in
boston whatever it was right
that's not an easy thing to do for
lebron to turn his friends into
individual stars themselves you know all
these other names maverick all these
guys that he's got
because that means you're growing and
they're growing yes that means you're
growing
you're lifting them up you got to give
the guy credit for being able to do that
that's not an easy thing
exactly that's why i think he's a
different wiring than kobe and
jordan i don't think he's the same
wiring as those guys no he's not
he he's not he's not yeah he
but that just shows you there's more
ways there's more than one
there's more than one path to winning
there's more than
there's more than one way to get there
yeah you said the opening you said
listen there's not a steps to it you
said
you know winning i can't give you the
steps there's not like a formula
but the guy that's going to win he's
going to figure out a way to do it his
own way he's going to eventually get
and that's exactly what you said listen
you and i
in this in this line of speaking
we don't tell people what to do
that was one of the biggest criticisms i
got about
relentless was you didn't tell it well
your whole life everybody's telling you
what to do
all right how you got to where you're at
how i got to where i'm at where how
these individuals that we talk about
in the in the book there's the ability
to what to think
and how to think and there's a huge
difference
everybody a lot of the people in our
space it's all about
the they give you information this is
how you need to think
this is the way it's done here here it
is
you lose your ability to how to think
and when you learn to combine the both
and that's what winning requires you to
do it's not it
it needs you to gather the information
but it also needs you
to be able to think on your own the onus
has to be on the individual
at the highest level to want to make
that decision you can kind of tell them
where you can you know here's what you
may want to think about
here's this here's what this person did
here's what this person did but what do
you want to do
the onus has to be on the individual to
want to take it at whatever levels they
want to do but see they want it simple
because
when you ask them what do they want to
do they don't know they want you to tell
them
they want you to tell them i don't think
four to one percent of the one percent
i don't think that the one percent of
one percent i don't think it works with
those guys
i think for i think you can't get into
one person and show people here if you
do this you're going to get this if you
do this you're going to get this
but there's the additional psycho level
to go through that it's so much pain
that
you got to be willing to go through that
i don't think you can do that for
everybody anyways
uh look if you're watching this when
when tim comes out with a book
i don't wait for it i read it if you've
not read relentless
or this you got to buy both of them i'm
not even recommending you just buy this
book of course you got to buy this book
we're going to put the link below for
you to go buy it
that'll be at the top of the link to buy
this book but on the bottom when you're
ordering it if it gives you the option
to also buy relentless
i highly recommend you buy both and read
both but obviously this is one that just
came out
i highly recommend you go get that book
tim once again appreciate you for coming
out my pleasure and uh being on
valuetainment i i
every time i'm with you i walk away
getting
you know tips here and there mindset i'm
like oh this is great you know i'm
getting sharper and sharper because your
content
speaks my language and you know what i
know you've had some unbelievable guests
on this show
i know you've put on some unbelievable
events and i've been honored to be a
part of those events
and that's that's special because i know
everybody
wants that invitation but very few have
gotten it and i appreciate that any time
i appreciate it for coming out you got
it thank you learning about the mindset
of winning never gets old especially
when it's coming from tim grover if
you've enjoyed the interview
comment below and if you haven't seen my
first interview with them click over
here
or if you've never seen the interview
with kobe bryant click over here take
care everybody bye